Prof: With Canto IV of
Paradise,
we are now in the Heaven of the
Moon,
which as you know by now is
also the heaven of grammar,
and I will show you in what way
this is the heaven of grammar.
In Paradiso III,
Dante meets two women,
the empress Constance,
and the irony of the name is a
little bit obvious among the
inconstant spirits,
and Piccarda.
Piccarda who also had joined
the cloister had taken the name
of sister Constance;
she too was forced to leave the
cloister on account of her
brothers, Corso Donati's
political maneuvers.
He wanted her married to an
ally of his.
With Canto IV,
Dante returns on this issue,
which is the issue really of
the will.
What is the will?
How can somebody else's force
on me, compel me to do things
that I am accountable for?
In what way am I accountable
for somebody else's imposition
of, in this case,
his will on me,
Dante wants to know what is the
will here?
There is another question that
forces him to--
another problem forces him to
raise a question in Canto IV,
and the question is Dante's
wonder about the souls in the
various stars.
They are disposed and arranged
in the various planets;
he sees some souls here on the
Moon, so he wonders are we in
Plato's paradise?
Is this--is Plato right in
believing that the souls at
death return to the stars,
to the place of origin?
These are the two questions
that he has to raise.
The canto begins with a
statement that is an
extraordinary--
I will try to explain how the
two questions are related,
in what way they are related,
they are not just absolutely
arbitrary.
There is a sort of link between
them.
Canto IV begins in a very--with
a rather strange formulation
about the nature of the will and
the freedom of the will.
Since that is what Piccarda's
situation had forced Dante to
raise, what is the will?
It's somebody else's will
forcing me to do something?
Am I still responsible for it?
Dante has to clarify what the
will is, so he starts with a
statement that seems to suggest
that the will is inert.
This is a poem that the will
cannot really make decisions,
first of all.
The will, given the opportunity
to choose between two
contradictory objects of desire,
can't quite move one way or the
other.
You need the intellect,
that's the argument that makes
the will take--make a decision,
will force the will to make a
decision.
And this is the way he starts,
"Between two foods at
equal distance and equally
tempting a free man would die of
hunger before he brought either
to his lips--
so a lamb would stand between
the cravings of two fierce
wolves,
in equal fear of both."
There seems to be a kind of
will that joins human beings and
animals,
such that paralyzes us,
the choices paralyze the will,
so that maybe when we speak
about freedom of the will we are
not speaking really about
freedom of the will,
we're speaking about the
freedom of the will in the
intellect.
It's the intellect that has to
be free so that's really the
argument.
"So would a hound stand
between two does;
therefore,"
this are three images that
introduce Dante's own doubts and
perplexities.
He has two questions;
each of them seems more
compelling than the other and
does not know what to ask first.
"So would a hound stand
between two does;
therefore, if I kept silence,
urged equally by my doubts,
I neither blame nor commend
myself, since it was of
necessity.
I was silent,
but my desire was painted on my
face and with it my question,
far more warmly than in plain
words."
Dante is indeed talking about
the limitations of the will not
that the will is--this is an
Averroist position.
It's a position of a radical
interpretation of Aristotle.
That the will is inert,
that you always need some kind
of-- the power of the intellect
to make you decide.
The intellect cannot move but
the intellect can make the will
move so that the statement has
to be understood as one of the
hierarchy between intellect and
will.
The argument now continues.
"Beatrice did as did
Daniel when he appeased the
wrath of Nebuchadnezzar that
made him cruelly unjust,
and she said:
'I see well how one desire and
another draw thee,
so that thy eagerness itself
binds itself and does not get
breath.
Thou reasonest:
'If the right will endures,
on what ground does another's
violence lessen the measure of
my desert?'"
How can it be that Piccarda,
who was forced by somebody
else's will,
seems to appear in the lowest
birth of beatitude?
She is on the Moon.
Why should she be so
undeserving of a closer intimacy
to God?
That's actually his question.
"Also, it gives thee
perplexity that the souls seem
to return to the stars,
in agreement with Plato's
teaching.
These are the questions that
press equally on thy will.
First, then,
I shall deal with that which
has more poison in it."
It's very interesting;
first of all,
the language of poison that
this idea of what is dangerous
of the two questions is not the
question about the will.
The question which is more
dangerous is the question that
deals with representation.
What is the mode of appearance
of the souls in heaven and why
should representation--do the
souls inhabit the stars?
Are they showing themselves
forth here?
It is a make believe that they
are here,
it's a fiction,
it's pyrotechnics if you wish,
and once the night is over then
the souls return to the proper
abode,
which or may not be visible to
the pilgrim.
Is this a theatrical
performance, and why if this is
a theatrical,
and it is, why should that be a
question that has more poison in
it?
What's so dangerous about
representation?
That's really the argument,
as Dante puts it forth,
here at the beginning at least.
She goes on--first of all let's
discuss it and then we'll--
as we discuss it we try to
understand the question why this
is representation such a hard
issue.
She says, "Not he of the
Seraphim,"
this is lines--
Paradiso IV,
lines 28, "that is most
made one with God,"
in the choir of angels,
those who are closest to God,
"not Moses,
Samuel, or whichever John thou
wilt--
;none,"
the apostle of the visionary,
the seer, "not Mary
herself,
have their seat another heaven
from these spirits that have now
appeared to thee."
This is the poetics of
Paradise,
by the way, that we are really
confronted with.
How do the souls show
themselves forth to the pilgrim?
What is the mode of Dante's
representation in
Paradise?
"From these spirits that
have now appeared--
nor for their being have more
years or fewer,
but all make fair the first
circle and hold sweet life in
different measure as they feel
more and less the eternal
breath.
These,"
what you are seeing here on the
Moon,
"have shown themselves
here,
not that this sphere is
allotted to them,
but in sign of the heavenly
rank that is least
exalted."
They have--they enjoy a lower
degree of beatitude than the
other souls so they just appear
here for your benefit.
In other words,
the whole of Paradise,
the representation of
Paradise if fictional and
once the pilgrim disappears so
will the souls vanish.
They will return into the bosom
of Abraham according to biblical
accounts.
"It is necessary,"
now Dante explains why the need
for this allegorization,
this allegorical language,
allegorical representation.
"It is necessary to speak
thus to your faculty,
since only from sense
perception does it grasp,
that which it then makes fit
for the intellect."
The whole of Paradise is
literally an accommodation of
varieties,
of realities that far exceed
the powers of our mind and now
its condescension.
The souls condescend to show
themselves down to us,
so Dante first of all,
has been talking about the
limitations of the will,
now he's talking about the
limitations of the intellect,
so these are the two issues
that join intellectually
speaking in Canto IV,
and each seems to need the
other and be made stronger in
the light of the other.
Dante goes on explaining this
mode of representation,
which he says is not only true
for Paradise,
but it's true for Scripture,
it's true for all the
iconography of the churches,
and that's what he says,
it's necessary to speak,
"For this reason Scripture
condescends,"
in the literal sense of the
word,
the etymological sense,
it comes down to us.
It accommodates itself to our
limited faculties,
"condescends to your
capacity and attributes hands
and feet to God,
having another meaning,"
that's the definition of an
allegory.
The Bible indeed speaks of the
hand of God;
it's an anthropomorphic trope,
God has no feet and has no
hand, but it means it's
something else.
It means that power of God or
the majesty of God,
the feet of God,
etc.
In other words,
there is a language of
representation even in the Bible
that in many ways authorizes
Dante's own juice of the
presentation.
Is this clear so far?
Good, there's no real
difficulty of this issue.
And then it continues,
"For this reason,"
it says that,
"and Holy Church,"
that's what happens in the
Bible when we talk about the
feet of God,
we read about the feet of God,
"Holy Church represents to
you with human aspect,"
angels that have no human form,
"Gabriel and Michael and
the other who made Tobit whole
again."
Now the distinction between the
metaphor, the platonic metaphor,
and the biblical allegory.
"What Timaeus argues about
the souls is not like that which
we see here;
for what he says,
he seems to hold for
truth," that's already one
basic difference.
It seems that what for the
Bible is a metaphor becomes true
in the context of Timaeus.
"He says,"
Plato says,
"the soul returns to its
own star,
from which he believes it to
have been separated when nature
gave it for a form."
He literalizes the idea of the
souls returning--
returned to the stars,
"but perhaps his view is
other than his words express and
may have a meaning not to be
despised.
If he means to return to these
wheels of the honour and the
blame of their influence,"
if by returning to the stars he
seems to imply that at the fall
of the souls,
the souls go through the
various stains of the planets
and then they return to the
planets from which they
originated,
"his bow perhaps strikes
on a certain truth.
This principle,
ill-understood,
once he misled almost the whole
world,
so that it went astray,
naming them Jupiter,
and Mercury,
and Mars,"
etc.
Dante's--then Beatrice
says--let me just continue,
"'The other doubt,"
this is the language of doubts;
intellectual doubts which are
always part of truth for Dante.
It's the truth that generates
doubt because the mind is
exactly the way he described the
will;
both are restless,
both need nourishment,
constant nourishment,
so these are intellectual
doubts.
"The other doubt that
troubles thee has less
poison,"
he repeats this idea,
less danger.
He hasn't said yet why the
world of representation is
dangerous.
And actually,
he leaves it at this;
"because its mischief
could not lead thee away from
me.
That our justice appears unjust
in the eyes of mortals is
evidence of faith."
We'll go back and we'll go in a
moment.
But let me stay with the first
question that Beatrice has
resolved for the pilgrim and for
us.
She's distinguishing between
the theology,
the biblical theology and let's
call it the philosophical
allegory;
biblical allegory and
philosophical allegory.
The language of metaphor in the
Bible and the language of
metaphor, truth in Plato.
Dante himself clearly is here
legitimizing his own use of
metaphor.
The whole poem is indeed a
metaphorical journey whereby
Dante is both simultaneously
biblical and also philosophical.
He's finding and trying to
decide on the common ground,
the metaphorical language that
the Bible and Plato will use,
and therefore himself.
Why is representation so
dangerous?
That it has so much poison in
it and Beatrice twice goes back
to that image,
and I think that the answer is
this.
That representation has the
power to cancel or erase the
world of references which it
represents.
Representation has the power to
make appearances the only
reality, simulacra,
the only reality that we manage
to see.
It literally covers,
it eclipses all references;
that's what makes
representation so dangerous.
It has a--we are by virtue of
the representation,
we end up in a kind of quandary
in the predicament of believing
that that's all that there is.
That which is visible is the
only real thing,
and invest--the appearance
invest that simulacrum with the
sort of value that it normally
does not have,
because it actually--it points
normally that doesn't have--
because it points for Dante to
essences behind it.
We have seen here the souls,
the souls are all--this is not
the real home for the spirits,
the real home is somewhere
else.
We may make the mistake Dante
made of believing that these
souls actually live on the Moon,
and therefore,
that we are in a platonic other
world,
in another world where the
souls go back to it.
The journey of Dante is the
journey between images and
testing of what these images may
mean,
finding out whether behind
these images there is some kind
of substance,
some kind of reality.
Dante literally moves between
the two worlds and things,
images, or representations and
in appearances and the world of
essences,
and tries to join the two of
them.
So you understand why
representation is the key issue
here.
Let me also add that this
discourse of allegory justifies
and gives you an idea why Dante
has been--
that this is the heaven of
grammar,
since the allegorical discourse
is a grammatical issue.
Remember that I have been
talking about each planet seems
to deploy--
well, one of the liberal arts,
but this is the reason why we
can connect grammar and the
Moon.
The other problem that Dante
raises in Canto IV is the
question of the will and he--
that's an easier issue because
he just goes on distinguishing
between what we call a
conditional will:
the will--
what we will whenever we are
beset by circumstances that
force on us some resolutions and
then absolute will:
the absolute will of the
martyrs of those who are,
for instance,
who are unwavering,
unfaltering in the
confrontation with particular
experiences.
The souls of this--of Piccarda
and Costanza,
they were really exercising
their own conditional will,
not their absolute will,
so it's an interesting
distinction and we leave it at
that.
We move now instead to the
heaven of Canto VI,
the heaven of dialectics,
of Mercury.
Why Mercury is the--why should
he be the god,
this is the planet Mercury but
the god tied with dialectics or
logic,
which are really not exactly
the same thing,
but Dante does use them
interchangeably.
Hermes is of course,
the god known as the
psychopomp, the one who
brings--do you know that part of
mythology?
The god who brings messages to
the realm of shades,
the realm of the dead that
carries the souls to Hades,
that's one of the ideas of the
resonances of Mercury.
Now there is also others,
the Mercury is the god who--
the bearer of laws,
the bearer of messages of the
gods to human beings,
the bearer of laws,
the god of the marketplace
though it doesn't seem to have
much impact,
a particular resonance of the
myth to this canto.
This is the logic--what is the
dialectics?
What are we to understand by
It's one of the arts of the
trivium and it is the art of by
which--by means of which,
which provides really a method,
that's the way it's defined.
It provides a method to
distinguish between truth and
falsehoods, so it's--let's see
how this is going to be present.
Interestingly enough,
Dante is really talking about
laws here,
and actually here he meets the
great theorist,
the Emperor Justinian who is
responsible and who is usually
acknowledged as the one who
favored the real organization of
Roman law in Byzantium,
which is where he lived.
Dante not only meets Justinian
but he also tells the story of
Rome, so it's a canto about
history.
The idea is what's the
rationality of Roman history,
is there a rationality to it?
If dialectics is also the
science of the power to
distinguish between falsehood
and truths,
it's also a rational
discipline, the discipline that
follows the rule of reason by
means of which one can go on
making those distinctions.
So the question becomes,
what is the rationality of the
Roman Empire?
What kind of justice was there
in it so laws,
and the same word logos,
seems to be ruling the
unfolding of this canto.
It begins with the story of
Constantine who we have met
before for the famous--as
accountable for the donation of
Constantine that you may know.
It's the famous alienation of
imperial property to the Church
for Constantine's token of
gratitude to the Pope,
Sylvester, who had cured him of
leprosy and this gave rise to a
famous,
much debated donation,
which Dante dismisses,
Dante views as nothing less
transgressive,
nothing less tragic and
disruptive of the order of the
world then for instance Adam's
sin.
It's really the same cosmic
proportion because it mixes
together the sacred and the
profane.
It makes the Pope a temporal
ruler and that is the ultimate
degradation of the moral
authority,
the exercise of moral authority
from Dante's viewpoint.
So, this is the illusion to the
donation,
but the illusion to the
donation here is taken into--
the reference to Constantine
has a slightly different sense.
"After Constantine,"
he says,
"turned back the eagle
against the course of heaven
where it had followed behind him
of old that took Lavinia to
wife,
for two hundred years or more
the bird of God,"
the eagle,
the emblem of the Empire,
"remained on the bounds of
Europe,
near the mountains from which
it first came forth;
and there ruled the world under
the shadow of the sacred wings,
passing from hand to hand,
and, so changing,
came into mine.
I was Caesar,"
the imperial title,
the imperial persona has
disappeared and now he appears
as "I am Justinian."
Here, once again,
the use of that shift of verbs
from the past to the present,
"And now,
I am in the eternal life,
I am myself a Justinian,
"who,
by will of the Primal Love
which moves me,
removed from the laws what was
superfluous and"
and then made the
distinction."
This is really a definition of
dialectics.
Made the distinction between
what was "superfluous and
vain" and what was
essential.
Let me give a gloss on this
first paragraph,
the allusion is to
Constantine's moving,
that's the other sense,
not only the donation,
but moving the seat of the
empire from Rome to the east,
Byzantium.
This is seen as the violation
of a metaphor of history,
a paradigm of history,
which was called
translatio
imperii.
What is this? What does it mean?
It's the idea of,
you know in the Middle Ages
they speak of translation,
all the time the translation of
studies, translation of the
empire.
The idea that the whole of
history follows a pattern,
a movement from east to west,
and therefore,
the duration of history is
patterned on the movement of the
Sun from east to west and with
the idea that when the empire
reaches the most western point,
the western most point of the
map that's going to be also the
end of history.
It's the end of the day,
the sunset, and the end of
history.
Constantine,
by turning back this
translation,
this movement,
that's what it means,
a transport,
a transfer of the Empire
actually delays the apocalyptic
denuma,
the end of time and the end of
the day,
and for Dante this is a major
violation of the economy of
history.
It begins with this idea of a
violation, a tragic violation of
history brought about by
Constantine.
The allusion of course is--the
other illusion is to Aeneas with
whom the Empire had started
after the fall of Troy had
started to go westward and then
Constantine reverses all of
this.
You understand,
by the way, this is--I mean,
this as on Election Day;
I really should mention this,
that the whole idea of manifest
destiny is really based on this
principle of the
translatio
imperii,
because the Empire moves
westward all the time.
We are now, therefore,
in the proper compass of
history, so to speak.
So, Constantine,
with the Lavinia who went
backwards, Lavinia wife of
Aeneas.
I must also indicate to you,
and this would become--
if case you are still looking
for a topic,
this is one of the first times
that Dante starts using this
geographical coordinates,
the geographical description of
Europe.
He has really not done that
neither in Inferno nor in
Purgatorio,
but now Europe becomes an
increased concern of his.
Whatever historical information
they have of it and it's--
this is the Europe at the east
and Dante will be talking about
the borders of Europe in the
west.
There is a kind of idea of a
Europe that has--he's asking
what kind of messages can come
from Europe which is still
valid, legitimate today.
These are the sort of
incredible questions that he
will ask and distinguishes
between Rome and Europe,
in the sense that Rome,
he will say,
in a political tract that he
writes,
that the history of Rome is
different from the history of
Europe,
1320 he writes this kind of
thing;
1318 maybe he writes this tract.
The emblem for Europe's--for
Rome's distinctiveness is to be
found in Aeneas' experience of
marrying three wives.
He marries Creusa,
as we'll hear from the
Aeneid;
he marries Dido,
though it's a marriage of
convenience so to speak but it's
a marriage, and then he marries
Lavinia.
Dante goes on to explain the
three wives he marries are one
from Asia,
one from Africa,
and one from Europe,
so that Aeneas' whole
experience, whole history
encompasses what at the time was
thought of as universality,
the three known continents in a
way of which only Europe,
Europe is only a part,
so keep that in mind.
I will talk more about this
metaphor as it appears.
Now this is the context of
Europe, so Justinian and the
reference to his reorganization
of the Roman code known as the
Justinian Code and then now we
have a history of the Empire.
From the emperor we have what
seems to be a celebration of the
Roman Empire,
this is Canto VI,
therefore like Canto VI of
Inferno and Canto VI of
Purgatorio,
the focus is political;
it's not just the city or Italy
now, it's the whole Empire.
But what begins as a
celebration of the empire in
effect turns out to be a
critique of the ideology of the
Empire,
the mythological reading that
we can find in Augustine's
Confessions.
Dante follows two models here
and they are two models that are
contradictory with each other
and in this representation of
Canto VI we have the Virgilian
model of the Roman Empire,
which is really a celebration
of its origins with Aeneas,
with Pallas,
the whole account told in the
Aeneid and with the
vision of what is to come.
But then there is,
around the fifth century,
A.D.
Augustine writes in The City
of God, a fierce critique of
the Empire.
The Empire has fallen,
the claims by the time
Augustine writes,
the claims of the eternity of
the Empire turn out to be
Apollo,
and to Augustine the Empire is
nothing less than another one
of--
another episode in a long
history of predatory politics of
imperial possessions and
violence.
The Roman Empire as an empire
is no better than all the other
empires that have long been--
have long vanished and
vanquished so this is the--
these are the two models that
Dante's evoking.
In fact, the very language,
just to give you an idea,
at one point Dante will say,
"Thou knowest,"
lines 35 and following,
"that it made its
stay," the eagle,
the story is told through the
vicissitudes of this emblem,
of the symbolic emblem,
the eagle, "for three
hundred years or more,
til at the last,
still for its sake,
the three,"
the razi,
you may know a little bit of
Roman History,
the Curiazi,
who fight it out with a duel
between the three brothers and
the other three brothers.
"The three fought with the
three,
and thou knowest what it did
under seven kings,"
the story of the seven kings,
"from the wrongs of the
Sabine women to the woe of
Lucrece,
conquering the neighbour
peoples round about."
These are all phrases that come
straight out of Augustine's
City of God.
They are used as cases of
exemplifying the libido of power
of Rome.
There are erotic stories,
stories of erotic violence;
Lucretia, who has been raped,
and the story of the Sabine
women who have been kidnapped by
the bands of Romulus and Remus,
and they are the outlaws.
There is this idea that the
Empire was born in the condition
of outlaws.
Dante is using the perspective
of Augustine because Augustine
had used these examples to them,
the Empire, and its own
aberrant policies.
At the same time,
all the rest is really
Virgilian;
this is the moment when Virgil
and Augustine really disagree
from each other.
Why does Dante do this?
What is this--what is the
reason for bringing together two
contradictory sources of
historical thought?
What's the idea of poetic
mythology of Rome?
Is he in favor of the Empire or
is he against the Empire?
Is he with Augustine or is he
with--actually with Virgil?
One thing is clear,
that Augustine who loves
Virgil, of course,
decides that this is--that the
Empire is an aberrant reality in
his own history.
It's already falling apart and
he has no use for this.
In his theological vision,
the question that he raises is,
what do I care who governs me,
provided this is he that they
do not make me sin.
The reality is an internalized
reality.
The reality is the one which is
in the interior life of all of
us and what are empires,
if not great thefts?
He will go on dismissing all of
this, he a Roman citizen at the
end, at the twilight of the
Empire, sixth century or so.
What is--where does Dante stand
in between them?
He continues.
I have an answer I hope.
He continues for now;
he doesn't tell us yet,
"Thou knowest what it did
when borne by the illustrious
Romans against Brennus…
It brought low the pride of the
Arabs,
who behind Hannibal passed the
Alpine crags from which,
Po, thou fallest.
Under it, as youths Scipio and
Pompey triumphed…
Then near the time,"
etc.,
this will continue into the
violation of the Rubicon by
Caesar and it--
then it goes on with
Charlemagne, line 95 and
following and now let me just
read the passage,
the last passage.
"Now thou canst judge of
such men as I accused before,
and of their offenses,
which are the cause of all your
ills;
the one opposes to the public
standard the yellow lilies and
the other claims,"
lilies of France,
"and the other claims it
for a party,
so that it is hard to see which
offends the more.
Let the Ghibellines,"
the canto all of a sudden
becomes evocative;
seems to turn into a replica of
Inferno VI of the Civil
War between Guelfs and
Ghibellines.
It starts as a celebration,
an encomium of the Empire and
its role in history,
in this westward movement
toward an apocalyptic
conclusion.
Now all of a sudden it goes
back to,
"Let the Ghibellines carry
on their arts under another
standard,
for of this he's always a bad
follower who serves it from
justice;
and let not this new Charles
strike at it with his Guelfs,
but let him fear its claws
which have torn the hide from a
greater lion.
Many a time ere now have the
children wept for the father's
fault, and let him not think God
will change arms for his
lilies."
What is this?
It starts with the Empire,
ends up with the civil war,
and the civil war is really the
perspective from which Dante can
take this double view on the
history of the Empire,
where Dante can really stand up
to the stance of Augustine and
the stance of Virgil.
What he really seems to be
saying I think is this,
yes Augustine you are right,
that the Empire is really a
negative force--
has been a negative force in
history and that the reality is,
as you say, an internalized
reality of our own peace and the
kind of internal will that we
can-- we manage to placate.
At the same time,
he says to Virgil but you're
also right in your valorization
of the Empire because the Empire
has brought about some order and
laws into the world.
That's the argument,
and yet, against Augustine he
says,
if there were no laws and there
were no laws of the Empire,
then there would be no way of
sheltering each and every unrest
in case of a civil war.
What makes the argument for the
necessity of the Empire is the
reality of the civil war which
really demands the presence of a
transcendent institution that
will manage to contain the
violence of human beings.
You can see he agrees with
Augustine and disagrees with
Augustine.
He agrees with Virgil and
disagrees with Virgil.
Virgil leaves no room for the
internal, the inner experiences
of Christians.
On the other hand,
Augustine leaves no room for
the necessity of an outside
structure that could order the
appetites of human beings.
The canto though comes to an
end with a little bit of an
autobiographical poetry,
an autobiographical picture.
This is now the emperor who
praises a counselor,
a counselor who has fallen into
disgrace.
"'Within the same pearl
shines too the light of
Romeo," Romeo Villeneuve,
a Provencal courtier,
who had the role of exactly
being a counselor for the
prince,
"whose great and noble
work was ill rewarded;
but the Provencals who wrought
against him do not have the
laugh,
and indeed he takes an ill road
who makes of another's
well-doing a wrong to himself.
Raymond Berenger had four
daughters, each of them a queen,
and Romeo, a man of low birth
and a stranger,
did this for him.
And when crafty tongues moved
him to call to account this just
man, who rendered him seven and
five for ten,
Romeo left there poor and old;
and if the world knew the heart
he had, begging his bread by
morsels, much as it praises him
would praise him more.'"
It is an oblique representation
of Dante himself,
who has to end up begging in
poverty for a morsel,
as he says, out of the
selfishness of the political
powers.
The other final question that I
think underlies this whole canto
that has to be raised is,
what is the relationship
between dialectics and this
representation of history?
Why should Dante connect the
two?
Why in the heaven of logic,
let's say, does he have to talk
about history?
I think that the idea is that
history itself,
I think that he's--this is an
encomium that ends up being not
quite a mitigated encomium.
It's also a critique of the
Empire,
that there is a reason within
the Empire and yet this reason
doesn't quite justify all that
the Empire perpetrated in
history.
I think from this perspective
Dante is also forcing on us some
perplexities about the nature of
logic as an instrument of power,
as one that could justify all
possible powers.
So there is also a critique of
dialectics as much as there is a
critique of history.
We skip altogether,
because I think it's a little
bit more evident,
and you can,
if you read on your own,
you can see Canto VIII and IX,
the canto of rhetoric and the
rhetoric and love they are very,
IX especially, very clear.
We move instead to the Heaven
of the Sun,
she's a little bit--X,
XI and XII are--
I don't know that I'll be able
to finish all of Canto X but I
want to start the discussion.
We are in the Heaven of the
Sun, which is the heaven of
arithmetic,
numbers and here Dante goes on
talking about one model of the
Trinity that I will describe to
you in a moment.
Dante encounters the wise
spirits, the spirits of--
in fact we are going to see
very soon there are two wheels
of saints,
two garlands,
represented as two garlands of
old men who hold themselves by
the hand,
dancing around the Sun.
It is the dance of wisdom,
if you wish.
You can call it--you can also
refer to it as a kind of
reorganization of the
encyclopedia.
You may remember that I used
this metaphor at the beginning
of the course,
this idea that the Divine
Comedy tries to re-propose a
new circle of knowledge,
a way in which things can
really be known and the
encyclopedia means the journey,
education, as in a circle
because the mind moves around
through the various arts and
sciences, that's how you learn.
You return to what you already
knew from a different viewpoint
and you see things,
things are new.
But it's the Heaven of the Sun.
Let me just go on a little bit
with the canto and then we'll
try to bring out some of the
issues of Canto X.
"Looking on His Son with
the Love,
which the One and the Other
eternally breathe forth,
the primal and ineffable Power
made with such order all that
revolves in mind or space,
that he who contemplates it
cannot but taste of Him."
He begins with a Trinitarian
representation,
the Father, the Son,
joined together by the breath
of love.
That was the idea of the
Trinity, which is a unity;
that's the paradoxes of
arithmetic, of this theological
arithmetic, as an image of
fecundity.
God is being an image of love,
is generative of itself,
within His own unity.
Then Dante turns to us,
and that's the last time I
believe that he turns to us
readers, and he tells us to be
stargazers.
That's all.
That's all he's saying.
"Lift up thine eyes with
me then,
reader, to the lofty wheels,
directing them on that part
where the one motion strikes the
other,
and from that point take thy
pleasure in the art of the
Master,
who so loves it in His heart
that His eye never leaves it.
See how from there the circle
branches obliquely that bears
the planets to satisfy the world
which calls for them."
He directs our eyes to an
intersection of the ecliptic,
the cosmic equator,
and the ecliptic,
the ecliptic being a term that
describes the diurnal and annual
movement of the Sun.
Where they meet,
that crossing,
that directs our eyes there,
"if their track were not
aslant,"
etc.
"Stay now,
reader, on thy bench,
thinking over this of which
thou hast the foretaste,
and thou shalt have much
delight before thou art weary;
I have set before thee,
now feed thyself,
for the theme of which I am
made the scribes bends to itself
all my care."
Why does Dante think of the
Trinity in the Heaven of the
Sun?
This is the simple question
that we should ask;
I have a passage that I want to
read to you.
It's taken from--I think this
is the--it's taken from the
pseudo Dionysius,
you may have heard of--whom
Dante will mention,
he's a mystic.
He writes on the divine names,
he writes about how the
mystical hierarchy and this will
be explained to you a little bit
of the--
what is Dante's,
at this point,
semi-mystical theology,
semi-mystical idea of the
Trinity, this idea that
knowledge has to be love.
He begins with an idea of the
Trinity bound by love and that
knowledge has to be love.
Let me read this passage and
maybe we can go from there.
I call it a solar theology.
That is to say,
a theology of the Sun,
not about the Sun but solar;
the theology has to be
understood as the life of the
Sun itself.
Let me read this passage,
"Think,"
this is from 693B of the divine
names and following,
"Think of how it is with
our sun.
It exercises no rational
process, no act of choice,
and yet by the very fact of its
existence it gives light to
whatever is able to partake of
its light in its own way.
So it is with the Dood,"
a classical comparison here of
course of the Sun with the good
in the republic of Protinus in
the Aeneid and so on.
"So it is with the Good.
Existing far above the sun,
an archetype far superior to
its dull image,
it sends the rays of its
undivided goodness to everything
with the capacity,
such as this may be,
to receive it…
Such beings owe the presence
and their uneclipsed and
undiminished lives to these
rays… They abide in the
goodness of God and draw from it
the foundation of what they are,
their coherence,
their vigilance,
their home.
Their longing for the Good
makes them what they are and
confers on them their
well-being.
Shaped by what they yearn for,
they exemplify goodness,
and as the Law of God requires
of them,
they share with those below
them the good gifts which have
come their way."
I call it a solar theology in
the sense that Dante is the--
I think, thinking of theology
as--or God,
or the Trinity as a given,
as a fountain,
not the Aristotelian or mystic
or Augustinian idea of
causality.
We think of God as the one who
imparts a cause or a motion to
things, or a beginning and then
you have a teliology,
you have effect.
The idea of the Trinity here is
one of an inexhaustible source
that keeps giving and it gives
to all and we're all part of
this gift.
This is the idea.
I think that Dante is getting
this,
what I call the solar theology,
from a mystical text called the
pseudo Dionysius,
again not that he is a mystic,
but he indeed appears as one
who behind is the rationalist
façade of his thinking,
he's aware of depths and other
ways of thinking which are not
those of the rational route.
Let me just go from and
describe even more here what
happens with this Canto X.
Now Dante goes on seeing these
two garlands of saints and this
is--let me read;
he meets Aquinas and let me
read from this passage where he,
Aquinas, will go on giving and
naming the first encyclopedic,
this movement of sages,
lines 100 and following where
he says,
"I was of the lambs of the
holy flock that Dominic leads on
the path where there is good
fattening if they do not stray;
he that is next beside me on
the right was my brother and
master, Albert of Cologne,
and I am Thomas Aquinas.
If thou wouldst be thus
informed of all the rest,
fall after my words with thine
eyes, going round the blessed
wreath.
That next flame comes from the
smile of Gratian,
who served,"
canon law and civil law,
"the one and the other
court so well that it gives
pleasure in Paradise;
the other who next adorns our
choire was that Peter,
who like the poor widow,
offered his treasure to Holy
Church.
The fifth light,
which is the most beautiful
among us, breathes from such a
love that all the world below
hungers for news of it;
within it is the lofty mind to
which was given wisdom so deep
that, if truth be true,
there never arose a second of
such vision."
It's Solomon described through
a circumlocution as the fifth
light,
and the fifth light because in
numerical symbolism five stands
for the natural number,
which is to say,
that Dante casts very difficult
proposition,
Solomon as being naturally
perfect,
having a kind of perfection of
intellect.
It's a dangerous proposition.
In fact, Dante will go
on--Aquinas will go on in Canto
XIV,
look let me just explain what I
said before because it's not
quite true because the virtue
of--
the intellectual virtue of
Solomon consists in the fact
that he knew what to ask for
when he had to govern his
people.
He was the perfect king because
he knew what to ask.
You understand why this would
be a dangerous idea?
If you believe that there is a
perfection of the intellect
within the natural imminence,
fear, order,
where we live then it means
that there's no need for
Revelation.
There is no need for
intermediaries,
no need for Redemption.
If nature, the natural
intellect, is capable of
ascending as it has claimed here
for Solomon, then the whole
apparatus will collapse.
Dante will not believe it and
Aquinas will go back as
dramatically,
actually in Canto XIII saying,
let me just explain myself,
"Beside it is the light of
the candle which below in the
flesh was farthest,"
this is Augustine and then,
"the body from which he
was driven lies below in
Cieldauro,"
this is Boethius,
"and he came from
martyrdom and exile to this
peace.
See, flaming beyond,
the glowing breath of Isidore,
of Bede, and of Richard [of St.
Victor]
who in contemplation was more
than man,"
line 132,
then read this line because I
think it's a little bit more
interesting in the Italian than
it is in English,
"in contemplation was more
than man,"
"d'Isidoro,
di Beda e di Riccardo,
che a considerar fu più
che vero."
The word Dante uses is not
contemplation,
it's consideration,
and it's a key word for Dante
whose consideration means the
etymologies that of moving with
the stars.
That is if the mind is at its
most perfect when it imitates
the circulation and circularity
of the stars;
consider, it's also like desire
by the way.
"This one from whom thy
look returns to me is the light
of a spirit to whom,
in his grave thoughts,
dealt seemed slow in coming;
it is the eternal light of
Siger, who, lecturing in the
Street of Straw,
demonstrated invidious
truths."
The last one that Aquinas
points out in this circulation
of wise spirits is one of a
so-called heretic by the name of
Siger of Brabant,
who was an Averroist and was
condemned for his Averroism.
Whatever knowledge and whatever
canonized knowledge we may have,
for Dante it includes figures
who have been judged unworthy of
knowledge or heretical or wrong
and now they are retrieved.
The idea of knowledge is one
that keeps changing.
The idea of the canor of
knowledge keeps always expanding
and including voices that had
been rejected.
Let me tell you more about this
representation of Siger of
Brabant.
You understand he's an
Averroist and we do know,
how does Dante go about--just
saying he's here,
how does he go about justifying
his salvation?
Canto X, from this point of
view, is retrospectively one
that sheds light on Canto X of
Inferno,
where we also saw,
you remember,
the Averroists and the
Epicureans,
Guido Cavalcanti,
those who believed that the
mind,
that love and knowledge never
interact with each other,
that the mind goes--rationality
is darkened and dimmed by the
infusions of passions,
remember, and that the mind is
one that receives ideas from the
outside,
or that notion of both the
inertia of the will and the
divisions within the mind
itself.
Dante now is correcting some of
those views.
So let's look a little bit at
these metaphors in Canto X.
"This one from whom thy
look returns to me is the light
of a spirit to whom,
in his grave thoughts,
death seemed slow in
coming."
He was killed,
by the way, by a madman and
Dante writes a sonnet about him
in around 1281 or so.
"It is the eternal life of
Siger," so we know that
he's saved,
"who lecturing in the
Street of Straw,
demonstrated invidious
truths."
Dante gives the address of this
man.
He lectured,
a word that has a certain value
in the university language,
a university lexicon of the
time.
Lecturing is an activity that
implies glossing,
just as is the glosseta of
Aristotle,
but he tells us where he lived,
in the Street of Straw in
Paris,
a street that now is called by
the way,
the Rue de Voir,
but is now called the Rue
Dante,
knowing that clearly the
Parisians are mindful of this
passage.
Dante is placing Siger on the
road,
on the way, he's giving us his
address but he is telling us
that his thinking takes place
while he is on the road.
You all know that philosophy is
always understanding itself as a
journey,
a method, an exodus,
Parmenides, or a quietness of
things about the five ways to
reach the ultimate truths about
God.
Dante is a philosopher,
is on the way to theological
certainty,
theological truth and
theological knowledge and he
"demonstrated invidious
truths."
The Italian is
sillogizzò,
made syllogisms out of,
demonstrated,
rationally demonstrated
invidious truths.
What are these invidious truths?
Invidious truths,
I'm not sure that all the
translators would agree.
Invidious truths have to be
understood etymologically.
This is the canto where Isidore
of Seville is presently--
Isidore of Seville being the
arch etymologist of the Middle
Ages and Dante is showing how he
too we can play with
etymologies.
Isidore of Seville is the one
who believed that whole of
knowledge,
all we know,
the compass of all knowledge
can really be arrived at through
etymologizing language.
Language, the etymon of
language, the origin of words
will give us an access to the
nature of reality,
so language becomes a way of
knowing the world.
Dante indulges in the same
activity calling the truth that
Siger pursued
"invidious,"
which etymologically means
those things,
those truths that cannot be
demonstrated,
seen.
Philosophy appears as an art of
speculation that takes us on the
way to a truth that it cannot
quite have access to.
What are these truths that
Siger of Brabant sought access
to?
The immortality of the soul,
there is no way he would have
known or even discovered that.
Aristotle is very doubtful
about the individual immortality
of the soul and the treatise of
the soul.
He tried to consider--to
view--to decide about the origin
of the world.
Siger believed that the
universe is another one of those
indemonstrable believes,
that the universe is eternal
and this is an argument that saw
medieval thinkers and
theologians engaged in,
Averroism on the one side and
Aquinas who maintains that
philosophically you really can
believe and show that the
universe is really,
is eternal.
But out of faith you can go on
believing in creation,
that things have a beginning,
but if you don't think that
things have a beginning,
then there's never a
possibility of allowing for
giving some ground and rooting
the idea of your freedom,
your innovations,
the possibilities things can be
different from you from what
they were before and so on.
The reason why Dante rescues
Siger of Brabant is a way for
him to be ultimately thinking
and making a statement that
whatever we believe that is
knowledge,
it's never definite and it's
always--
we are literally on the way and
rethinking it and making it all
the time an object of our own
self-critique.
This is not the only place
where Dante is rethinking
himself.
Very soon around the notion of
the Trinity,
Bonaventure will have to change
his mind about a man,
a figure that I have mentioned
before,
Joachim Flora,
in the next canto.
The idea with a Joachistic
interpretation of history,
so he will--we are going to
have to have Canto XI balancing
off Canto X.
Then it ends,
the canto ends,
"Then,
like a clock,"
what an extraordinary image,
an image of time now,
but what I have to say is that
you probably do not know that
clocks,
mechanical clocks,
the way we still see them were
a recent technological invention
in the late thirteenth century
which Dante is absorbing here.
"Then, like a clock that
calls us at the hour when the
bride of God rises to sing
matins to the Bridegroom that he
may love her,
when one part draws or drives
another,
sounding the chime with notes
so sweet that the well-ordered
spirit swells with love,
so I saw the glorious wheel
move and render voice to voice
with harmony and sweetness that
cannot be known but there where
joy becomes eternal."
Dante is describing these songs
of the eternal--
of the blessed souls in erotic
terms,
so that what seems to be a
canto of pure knowledge
ultimately becomes a love song
too and this is the whole
trajectory of Canto X.
Let me stop here and see if
there some questions about these
three cantos which I'll be glad
to answer.
They are a little bit abstract
but I think that they respond to
genuinely interesting and
historical problems at least.
The question of allegory at the
beginning--let me just give you
a kind of quick resume of what
we said.
In Canto IV you have two
issues, you have the issue of
allegory and the issue of the
will where Dante goes on
explaining the mode of
representation in
Paradise as a mode of
accommodation to our limited
faculty and he thinks that this
is really the mode of
representation throughout the
Bible,
the iconography of the Church,
the poem,
etc., which is a way therefore
of talking about allegory in a
slightly different form from the
way he spoke of it in,
as you remember what I spoke of
it,
but he was allowing us to do
that in Canto IX of
Inferno where we had been
talking about the allegory of
poets, allegory of theologians.
Now there is no question that I
think that there is no intrinsic
difference between the two
modes.
Remember that I used to talk
about the allegory of
theologians as being an allegory
where the literal level is true
and the allegory of poets as one
in which the literal level is a
fiction.
Now I'm saying that both of
them for Dante have a kind of
metaphorical basis and the
relationship between the
metaphor and truth is,
of course, it's certainly the
language of a very similitude,
if not absolutely the truth.
Then the two--the other issue
about the will,
the limitations of the will,
the conditional and absolute
will.
When we come to Canto VI of
Paradise Dante shifts
gears altogether and talks about
history, and the framework of
the Empire.
Is it providential,
I call it what is the
rationality of the Empire,
but the real issue is,
is there such a thing as a
providentality of the Empire,
which he had maintained
in--elsewhere in the poem and
certainly in the text of
Monarchia.
Dante concludes now,
seems to have to explain,
give an apology for his belief
in the Empire by agreeing with
and siding with Virgil,
but at the same time giving a
critique of the Empire and
acknowledging Augustine,
but manages to criticize both.
Both Augustine and--for
different reasons and Virgil had
not seen the whole truth;
Virgil can go on into unabashed
loudatio,
laudatory statements about the
Empire.
Augustine can go on damning the
Empire but Augustine does not
understand that if within the
context of the civil war where
the realities where Corso can
turn against his sister
Piccarda,
where the Guelfs can go against
the Ghibellines,
where your own brother can be
your enemy,
that's really what it's about.
Then you do need some kind of
law.
You read an outside world,
an outside institution that can
guarantee and protect yourself.
The claim that salvation is
only in the interiority of the
soul,
which is Augustine's claim,
is not really sufficient for
someone who is--
as Dante was involved in the
public's fear and the public
life.
I think that these are the two
most important moments.
In Canto X Dante is moving
beyond the--it's a poetic break
that takes place.
He literally moves us beyond
the sunlight,
the daylight of the ordinary
natural daylight moving into a
world now which is his own and
Dante starts raising the issue
of knowledge,
as if to say that a new
knowledge, a new way of thinking
now is necessary.
Once you move beyond the
ordinary boundaries of the
universe you got to have--you
start asking yourself what kind
of knowledge do I need here.
He's rethinking therefore the
whole relationship between truth
or knowledge and error,
heresies and knowledge,
the canonical certainties that
Aquinas would have who now makes
significantly enough a mistake
about the fate of Solomon and
Siger of Brabant,
so that seems to be the
argument that is running in
these cantos.
He is forcing on us a different
way of thinking and that
different way of thinking begins
with a redefinition of nothing
less than the Trinity.
The idea of causality,
not the idea of efficiency,
causa efficiens,
that's the way God is defined
by Aquinas,
that's the way that Augustine
defines--
he writes a treatise on the
Trinity with the idea of God as
causality.
Dante adds -- doesn't exclude
the others;
it would be inconceivable that
something as imponderable as the
Trinity could just have one
formula to account for it,
but he adds onto it that first
definition of the Trinity as a
unity of love and a unity of
fecundity which I think is a
mystical definition.
The idea of God,
the idea of creation is one of
participation of the creatures,
the idea of God as being the
source,
the inexhaustible source of
light and not just efficiency
and not just etiology,
movement, etc.,
and we shall see the
implications of this.
Yes.
Student:  I was just
wondering why is it such a
problem for Dante to imagine
like a perfect natural intellect
in Solomon,
because isn't it sort of
Inferno and
Purgatorio sort of a
perfection of the will through
Virgil's intellect and Virgil's
reason,
and so why is it a dangerous
proposition to say that a man
could have a perfect intellect?
Prof: The question,
a very good question,
is why does Dante find it so
difficult to acknowledge the
perfection of Solomon's
intellect,
when after all,
in Inferno and
Purgatorio,
we have had some accounts of
how the will is moved by the
intellect and perfected by the
intellect.
Am I paraphrasing
your--actually repeating what
you said I think,
but accurately?
It's a very good question;
it's really a complicated
problem.
In fact, I think that what you
have to keep in mind how Dante
talks about Solomon as a people
on Earth are so anxious--
this was one of the most
incredibly debated--
is he saved?
Is Solomon saved?
Because he's the wisest,
that's what the Bible tells us,
he's the wisest,
and we believe the Bible--the
Middle Ages argument.
We believe in the Bible so he's
the wisest,
but he was also known as being
the most lecherous of kings,
so big solution for Dante,
forget about that,
he's really the wisest so he's
saved,
so that solves that particular
issue of the relationship
between love and knowledge and I
think that's a crucial point
in--
for the way you are stating the
issue because you are stating
how in Inferno and
Purgatorio you have the
will directed and reorganized by
the intellect,
so you see there must be some
kind of relationship between
will and intellect.
Dante here says,
the will was really was a
little bit--
was chaotic,
was disordered will,
so we have only to judge him in
terms of this majestic intellect
that he has.
In fact, he was the most
perfect of figures since Adam
was created in the Garden.
That's the first thing.
But now let me come to the crux
of the matter here.
If you believe that he had
intellect which was absolutely
perfect,
perfect intellect,
then what you're really saying
and this is the context of
knowledge,
a mathesis as the
Greek's call it,
the mathesis,
the word mathematics it comes
from that.
If you believe that then you're
really saying that philosophy is
the way to come to the truth.
You see what I'm saying?
If philosophy is the way to
come to the truth,
you don't really need theology
or you really have to start
thinking of theology as some
kind of vulgar poet or some
vulgar philosophizing,
as some kind of the poetry for
the masses,
for instance,
a kind of elitarian,
elite-like,
view that keeps creeping up
into--in the ways of thinking
about theology and philosophy
and if you believe that,
that philosophy is the mode.
In fact, now we have a
correction of the philosophers
immediately after with the
presence of Siger because of
course--
see the ambivalence Siger is
justified and saved because his
mind was a searching mind.
He's on the road,
he's a true philosopher
he--it's the method.
I was describing logic as a
method that the Greek word that
means "way."
It's the root,
the philosopher of the root,
philosophy is on the way out of
their odyssey,
the odyssey of the soul,
that's really--
we call it--Dante says exodus,
it's an exodus clearly
countering the idea of the
philosophical root.
There's another story,
another way of looking at
journeys,
he's certainly involved in a
journey,
a journey of the heart and a
journey of the mind at the same
time.
Once you go on,
Siger is on--there is--there
was no perfection.
He tried to demonstrate and
look at the paradox invidious,
that is to say,
truths that cannot be seen.
I appear to the etymology of
invidious.
Many translations and they say
unwelcome truths.
I don't know what kind of
translations,
actually I like my Sinclair who
says "invidious
truths,"
but many others translate that
word invidious as unwelcome or
the truths that made him be
scorned and hated by others
because the jealousy of
philosophers is a little bit in
the background.
He lost his life,
he was killed because of that,
but instead he is in pursuit of
truths which is the aim of
philosophy of all
investigations,
but philosophical
but cannot be demonstrated,
that cannot be seen so there is
a limitation of the
philosophical road of the road
of philosophy.
Indirectly, the limitation of
Solomon's perfect claim of--he
never claimed that he had a
perfect intellect.
In fact, Aquinas who realizes
what he has said,
he says no, no,
no the wisdom of Solomon has to
be viewed in his prudence for
asking God that he be given the
absolute knowledge in the
government of his people,
so it's a limited form of
knowledge but that was perfect.
It's--maybe it strikes you as
sophistry but I enjoy that.
Thank you so much.